and now we turn to this the last known
piece of writing from missing Saudi
columnist Jamal khashoggi appears this
morning in the Washington Post
it calls for press freedom across the
Arab world saying the region is facing
its own version of the Iron Curtain
imposed by domestic forces vying for
power his assistant sent the column to
the paper one day after khashoggi
entered Saudi Arabia's consulate in
Istanbul Turkey and vanished
president Trump says the u.s. wants the
Turkish government to release any audio
or video it may have of khashoggi
disappearance Leisha Jang is at the
White House where the president is still
holding back on criticizing the Saudis
we a good morning good morning beyond a
president Trump continues to praise
Saudi Arabia as an important ally and
refuses to say whether he has sent the
FBI to get involved meanwhile Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo is back in the u.s.
after meeting with Turkish and Saudi
officials he returned with no concrete
answers but he is pressing them to wrap
up the investigation soon and one Saudi
source tells CBS News it'll be done by
the end of the week
I'm not giving cover at all president
Trump pushed back against critics who
say he's letting Saudi Arabia get away
with murder they're an important ally
but I want to find out what happened
where is the fault the president said he
asked Turkey to turn over a recording
that state media reports proves Jamal
khashoggi was killed and dismembered
after entering the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul on October 2nd I'm not sure yet
that it exists probably does possibly
does Khashoggi was a critic of the Saudi
government Arab governments have been
given free rein to continue silencing
the media at an increasing rate to show
you wrote in his final column published
in The Washington Post the Arab world is
facing its own version of an Iron
Curtain imposed not by external actors
but through domestic forces vying for
power
Karen Atia is the global opinions editor
for the post it's a chilling reminder to
everyone to the world that speaking the
truth
can come at the ultimate price earlier
mr. Trump credited the kingdom for
supporting his decision to abandon the
Iran nuclear deal
we are stopping Iran we're not trying to
stop with stopping Iran and once again
focused on their financial relationship
they committed to purchase four hundred
and fifty billion dollars worth of
things and 110 billion dollars worth of
military a fellow Republicans have said
you can't put a price on credibility and
even president Trump's congressional
allies are pressing him to turn up the
pressure and take stronger action just
yesterday GOP Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell called for a credible
investigation and said I can't imagine
there won't be a response Gail yeah
there is a demand for answers thank you
very much we sure